[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
ihnen allen willkommen zu dieser letzten
woche vor weihnachten schön dass sie
wieder dabei sind genauso wie christian
otto für den sport ich freue mich auch
guten abend und das sind unsere heutigen
themen
omikron auf dem vormarsch nach
weihnachten könnten beschränkungen auch
für geimpfte ausgeweitet werden
geldpolitik in schweren zeiten joachim
nagel soll chef der bundesbank werden
und den spagat zwischen steigenden
preisen und corona geplagter wirtschaft
meister
analyse im aartal der
untersuchungsausschuss informiert sich
im flutgebiet über mögliche fehler bei
der katastrophen warnen
ja es sieht wieder nach schärferen
corona maßnahmen aus die werden höchst
wahrscheinlich morgen von bund und
ländern beschlossen dazu aber gleich
mehr zunächst zur risikoeinschätzung der
virusvariante omikron da zeichnet der
expertenrat der bundesregierung ein
ziemlich düsteres bild und warnt vor
einer überbelastung die noch über den
gesundheitsbereich hinausgehen könnte
grundlage der prognosen ist die extrem
beschleunigte omikron verbreitung zum
beispiel im hotspot london dazu antoine
kurschilgen
flughafen frankfurt heute morgen aus
großbritannien landen mehrere maschinen
wer von da kommt muss 14 tage in
quarantäne
denn in großbritannien schießen die
omikron zahlen in die höhe und das duo
auch uns sagt der expertenrat der
bundesregierung die neue mutation könnte
sich explosionsartig ausbreiten erste
studienergebnisse zeigen dass der
impfschutz gegen die omikron variante
rasch nachlässt und ihm ohne personen
symptomatisch erkranken boostern sei
sehr wichtig werde die omikron welle
aber nicht verhindern
aber man muss sich einfach darauf
vorbereiten dass das ein sehr ähnliches
virus ist in der krankheits stärke in
den krankheitsverlauf aber sehr viel
deutlich schneller übertragbar ist
deswegen geht der expertenrat davon aus
dass es sehr viele omikron patienten
geben würdest du eine erhebliche
überlastung der krankenhäuser durch
krankmeldungen quarantäne was auch
folgen für andere bereiche der
kritischen infrastruktur hätte wie
polizei und feuerwehr bis hin zur
müllabfuhr und
da kann man eben nochmal abstufung das
wirklich die hygienisch relevanten
abfälle ähnlich bio und restmüll als
erstes entsorgt werden auch da gibt es
eine priorität papier kommt dann im
nachgang um eine mögliche fünfte welle
zu mildern empfiehlt der expertenrat
folgende maßnahmen sofort konsequenzen
tragen von ffb zwei masken deutlich mehr
impfungen schnelltest auch bei
familientreffen während der festtage
sowie weitere kontakt beschränkungen
welche kontakt beschränkungen jetzt die
wichtigen sind oder ob das regional
unterschiedlich sein sollte das ist
etwas was die politik jetzt in den
nächsten wochen oder tagen entscheiden
soll bund und länder wollen bereits
morgen darüber beraten
ja es wird also ein zweites corona
weihnachtsfest geben gesundheitsminister
lauter war schließt einen lock down bis
dahin zur aus aber laut beschlusspapier
vor der morgigen bund länder runde wird
es schon sehr bald zu kontakt
einschränkungen kommen auch für genesene
und geimpfte aus berlin da wird
eine schöne bescherung nach dem
dramatischen appell des expertenrats
kommen morgen drei tage vor weihnachten
noch mal die regierenden zusammen bund
und länder wollen neue maßnahmen
beschließen um ii grund irgendwie
bremsen da gibt es dann auch noch
weitere beschränkungen was persönliche
kontakte betrifft damit wir gut
vorbereitet sind wenn die neue variante
des virus dann auch sich überall in
europa ausbreitet wir hören dass die
sehr infektiös ist und deshalb die
gefahr besteht dass sie viele erreicht
wesentliche kontakt beschränkungen für
großveranstaltungen auch im sport clubs
und diskotheken sollen ganz zu silvester
partys klein bleiben laut einem ersten
beschlussvorschlag für morgen sind ab
dem 28 dezember private zusammenkünfte
von geimpften und genießen nur noch mit
maximal zehn personen erlaubt für
private treffen zumindest wohl innen ich
glaube die große silvesterparty kann in
diesem jahr nicht stattfinden leider
wieder nicht aber omikron wird uns keine
nachlässigkeit verzeihen wenn wir da
jetzt nicht vorsichtig sind längst
spuckt das lockdown gespenst durchs
politische berlin gesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach hatte den bis
weihnachten ausgeschlossen aus den
reihen der grünhäute der vorstoß über
einen gut geplanten lockdown im januar
nachzudenken skepsis bei der fdp
die fdp weiß aber dass viele menschen in
unserem land sich vor einem neuerlichen
lockdown fürchten alle sollten sich
darum bemühen die menschen nicht zu
verunsichern
ich glaube wenn jemand da ist der
hinweise darauf hat dass omikron
deutschland nicht betrifft und das alles
kein problem ist dann soll er vor treten
wir tun gut daran im moment nichts
auszuschließen und so wird morgen manch
harte nuss zu knacken sein beim ausloten
geeigneter maßnahmen und der
schmerzgrenzen der verhandlungspartner
fragen wir nach bei theo koll in berlin
theo angesichts der lager das kanzleramt
ja vergleichsweise zahmen maßnahmen im
beschlusspapier formuliert wird es dafür
die zustimmung der länder geben morgen
ich denke schon dass dürfte mindestens
alles bleiben darüber ist soweit ich
weiß schon am wochenende auch mit dem
kanzler ausgiebig verhandelt worden
angeblich hat man sich heute nachmittag
dann zusätzlich darauf geeinigt dass
großveranstaltungen künftig wieder
komplett ohne zuschauer stattfinden
sollen also dann auch geisterspiele beim
fußball zu krach könnte morgen aber die
große frage führen reicht das alles was
ist wenn diese berüchtigte omikron wann
nach weihnachten vor uns auftaucht von
welle wird er ja schon kaum noch geredet
omikron verbreitet sich mit einer noch
nie dagewesenen geschwindigkeit die
niederlande sind ja deshalb seit gestern
im locker und auch der neue expertenrat
der bundesregierung hat wirklich
einstimmig alarm gerufen selbst wenn
sich alle krankenhäuser ausschließlich
auf notfälle und dringende eingriffe
konzentrieren würden wäre eine
angemessene versorgung dann nicht mehr
möglich das heißt die politik steht
morgen vor der frage ob eine
möglicherweise dramatische entwicklung
nicht auch dramatischere maßnahmen als
die jetzt geplanten erfordert danke nach
berlin theo koll
dann sind wir jetzt bei den aktuellen
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
1086 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind
5657 weniger als am vergangenen montag
119 todesfälle kamen innerhalb von 24
stunden hinzu die sieben tage incident
steigt jetzt leicht auf 316 ja hinter
all diesen zahlen stehen viele
wissenschaftler und labore die korona
zwar feststellen aber sich wünschen dass
es noch viel mehr sequenzierungen gibt
also genetische untersuchung positiver
tests um omikron frühzeitig erkennen zu
können mehr von nicola albrecht aus
potsdam aus der täglichen flut an
positiven pcr tests werden die omikron
verdachtsfälle herausgesucht und gleich
weiter untersucht acht stunden lang
müssen die fachleute hier im labor in
potsdam die proben dazu zunächst
aufbereiten dann geben sie sie in dieses
spezialgerät es analysiert welche
mutationen vorliegen dieses ergebnis ist
eindeutig die ersten omikron fälle sind
da das hatte jedoch von den anderen
varianten haufen mutationen drin hat und
also jeder bunte strich ist quasi eine
mutation doch das sogenannte
sequenzierung verfahren zur bestimmung
der virus varianten ist aufwändig in
potsdam dauert es dank neuester
technologie insgesamt zwei tage
anderenorts bis zu acht tage bundesweit
werden aufgrund fehlender infrastruktur
und mangel an kapazitäten in den laboren
nur etwa fünf bis zehn prozent der
positiven pcr tests sequenziert so hat
man bislang 240 bestätigte omikron fälle
laut lka und anderen instituten erkannt
die dunkelziffer dürfte deutlich höher
liegen es müsse mehr sequenziert werden
fordern experten
der positiven proben und einigermaßen
vernünftiges bild über die gesamtlage zu
bekommen es sind vor allem die
gesundheitsämter die auf die daten
angewiesen sind in potsdam leitet der
oberbürgermeister die korona task force
die omikron celle haben hier nun
priorität wird mit hochdruck
nachgegangen dh die kontakte nach
verfolgung wird umgehend eingeleitet und
wir versuchen möglichst das direkte
umfeld zu informieren und in quarantäne
zu übersetzen noch ist die delta
variante dominant doch omikron wird sie
überholen hier im labor sind sich
jedenfalls auf überstunden über
weihnachten eingestellt
mit möglichen langzeitfolgen von corona
hat sich die universität mainz
beschäftigt das ergebnis sechs monate
nach der infektion haben 40 prozent
aller infizierten lankowitz symptome wie
etwa müdigkeit schwindel oder
herzrhythmusstörungen
betroffen seien mehr frauen als männer
außerdem klagt jeder dritte infizierte
über eine verminderte leistungsfähigkeit
untersucht wurden mehr als 10.000
menschen
die europäische arzneimittelbehörde hat
den neuartigen corona impfstoff des
us-herstellers nova ves zugelassen einen
sogenannten protein impfstoff der
besteht aus künstlich hergestellten
spike proteine nimmt man damit dann
bildet der organismus antikörper bei den
gängigen m rna impfstoffen spritzt man
dagegen nur eine bauanleitung der
organismus baut dann die spike proteine
selbst und produziert eine immunabwehr
ob nowaks auch ausreichend vor der delta
und der omicron variante schützt das
wird noch untersucht gibt da viele
fragen rund um den fünften impfstoff
antworten finden sie bei uns zum
beispiel wie er funktioniert wie gut
erwürgt oder wieso manche menschen auf
bestimmte impfstoffe haben das und mehr
bereits hätte erfreute oder in der zdf-
heute
mehr zur corinna lage dann auch gleich
im anschluss an unsere heute -sendung in
einem zdf spezial
ein neuer bundesbank präsident wurde ja
gesucht und jetzt ist klar wer auf ihren
zweiten erfolg der sein amt zum
jahresende vorzeitig aufgibt ab dem 11
wird joachim nagel oberster notenbanker
in ziemlich unruhigen zeiten stichwort
inflation die zuletzt ja sehr stark
anstieg in der bundesbank auch im
vorstand hat der 55 jährige promovierte
ökonom bereits gearbeitet und
finanzminister lindner sagte nagel sei
eine erfahrene persönlichkeit die
kontinuität der bundesbank sichere
so also der finanzminister frank
bethmann in frankfurt an der börse ist
nagel der richtige was hört man denn da
na ja es gab bereits viel
vorschuss-lorbeeren heute allesamt mit
dem tenor der beste kandidat die man für
diese aufgabe gewinnen konnte
stellvertretend deutsche-bank-chef
seewegen in seiner funktion als
präsident des bankenverbandes damit
kommt ein experte mit langjähriger
notenbank erfahrung und ausgezeichneter
kenntnis der finanzmärkte an die spitze
der deutschen zentralbank die damit
verbundene hoffnung natürlich dass nagel
in der tradition früherer
bundesbank-präsidenten für die
stabilität des geldes wird sorgen können
das ist aber leichter gesagt als getan
denn auch wenn die inflation nicht
dauerhaft über fünf prozent bleiben wird
so rechnet die bundesbank für das
kommende jahr immer noch mit gut 3
prozent geldentwertung auf dauer zu viel
die große frage wird sein gelingt es
nagel künftig besser als seinem
vorgänger weit man mehrheiten im rat der
europäischen zentralbank zu organisieren
mehrheiten für höhere zinsen und weniger
inflation frank vielen dank für die
einschätzung nach frankfurt
bundeskanzler scholz ist nach seinen
antrittsbesuchen in brüssel paris und
warschau heute nach rom gereist dort
wurde er mit militärischen ehren begrüßt
scholz und ministerpräsident draghi
kündigten an das deutschland und italien
künftig enger zusammenarbeiten wollen
dazu soll es einen gemeinsamen
aktionsplan geben besprochen wurde in
rom auch über die sicherheitslage in
europa und über krone
die bundesregierung spricht von einer
neuen belastung im verhältnis zu
russland nach dem urteil im sogenannten
tiergarten mordprozess hat die russische
regierung reagiert und ihrerseits zwei
deutsche diplomaten zu unerwünschten
personen erklärt ein berliner gericht
hatte vergangene woche einen russen zu
lebenslanger haft verurteilt und dabei
von staatsterrorismus gesprochen zwei
russische diplomaten wurden daraufhin zu
unerwünschten personen erklärt und jetzt
zu einem thema das erschüttert nicht nur
den fußball drittligisten
wehen-wiesbaden ein ehemaliger
jugendtrainer sitzt in untersuchungshaft
der verdacht gegen ihn vergewaltigung
und sexueller missbrauch stefan
schlosser berichtet es sind
schwerwiegende vorwürfe ein 34 jahre
alter fußball trainer einer
jugendmannschaft des sv wehen wiesbaden
soll mehrere der ihm anvertrauten kinder
sexuell missbraucht haben bei einer
hausdurchsuchung konnte die
staatsanwaltschaft eindeutig belastendes
material sicherstellen unter anderem ein
mobiltelefon und auf diesen
mobiltelefonen wurden dann
videosequenzen festgestellt die zeigen
dass der beschuldigte sich im oktober
2021 an mehreren minderjährigen jungen
sexuell vergeht es handelt sich
insgesamt um sieben fälle der missbrauch
fand offenbar in der wohnung des
beschuldigten stadt dort soll er mehrere
kameras verbaut und so die taten gefilmt
haben die besonderheit ist die dass die
jungen also die opfer jeweils reglos bzw
besinnungslos wirkten so dass der
verdacht besteht dass sie zuvor durch
rauschmittel gefügig gemacht wurden
offenbar hat der 34-jährige bereits
zwischen 2007 und 2014 mindestens zwei
jungen missbraucht ein opfer hat sich
erst jetzt offenbart und die
ermittlungen ins rollen gebracht seit
anfang dezember sitzt der beschuldigte
in untersuchungshaft
ganz anderes thema vor fünf monaten
zerstörte die flut weite teile des
areals ihres häuser und menschen mit
sich
134 menschen starben tausende verloren
ihr zuhause allein die versicherten
schäden belaufen sich laut schätzungen
auf rund acht milliarden euro viele
menschen leiden bis heute auch psychisch
unter den folgen offen die frage warum
sie nicht früher gewarnt wurden und dem
geht ein untersuchungsausschuss des
rheinland pfälzischen landtags nach und
war heute morgen vor ort marion geiger
sie wollen erinnern an die menschen die
sie verloren haben überlebende und
hinterbliebene der todesopfer auf dem
campingplatz stahlhütte in goxel an der
a7 menschen kamen hier nicht mehr raus
aus der flut nach dem vielen regen am 14
juli die frage ob man sie vor der gefahr
hätte schützen können lässt den
überlebenden keine uhr hier auf diesem
camp in klassischer mit frühzeitige
warnung nicht alle personen sterben raum
da hätte man schon einfach
aus vorsicht sagen müssen bitte alle vom
campingplatz unter die anliegen sofort
und dass es nicht gemacht worden
der untersuchungsausschuss im mainzer
landtag soll die abläufe klären vor und
während der katastrophe von den
warnungen der meteorologen bis zu den
entscheidungen vor ort die frage stellt
sich am ende des tages ob es politische
verantwortung gab es ob es fehlverhalten
gab
menschliches fehlverhalten
organisatorische fehler die dazu geführt
haben dass hier in einer solchen anzahl
menschen ums leben gekommen sind hätte
man das verhindern können dass die
fragen die flut wälzte sich vom frühen
abend bis in die nacht durch das aartal
auch dort wo sie spät ankam wurden die
menschen noch überrascht von der gewalt
des wassers
die abgeordneten starteten heute mit der
beweisaufnahme ein geologe erläuterte
die besonderheit des anteils im januar
geht's weiter mit sachverständigen für
hydrologie und wettervorhersage
sie wissen der wintersport der läuft
schon auf hochtouren in 46 tagen genau
gezählt ja
schon stadt für die olympischen spiele
und es gab heute schon eine schöne
überraschung absolut das macht wirklich
lust auf mehr skirennfahrer alexander
schmidt hat sich beim weltcup im
italienischen alta badia einen großen
traum erfüllt in seiner spezialdisziplin
den riesenslalom schaffte er als dritter
erstmalig den sprung aufs podest
riesige freude bei alexander schmid der
allgäuer zeigt in südtirol zwei starke
läufe und feierte den größten erfolg
seiner karriere ich bin mir selber treu
blieben und sich einfach waren sie das
jan tauer helfen wichtigen berger podest
stehen darf herrschenden beim
riesenslalom klassiker auf der
anspruchsvollen strecke fährt schmid
angriffslustig zeitweise auf einer
perfekten ihm erstmals gehört der
27-jährige jetzt zur absoluten
weltspitze platz eins geht an den
schweizer marco odermatt werden vierten
saisonrennen den dritten sieg holt
zweiter wird vize-weltmeister luca der
aliprandi
am tag nach dem erstmaligen abbruch
eines deutschen profi fußball spiels
wegen rassistischer beleidigung des
osnabrücker spielers opoku haben sich
der msv duisburg und der vfl osnabrück
übereinstimmend für die wiederholung der
partie ausgesprochen der abbruch stößt
auf große zustimmung ein konsequent
richtiges zeichen gegen rassismus und
für menschlichkeit gegen den 55 jährigen
beschuldigten wird ermittelt
harter schnitt glanzvoller
jahresabschluss gestern abend in
baden-baden bei der traditionsreichen
gala sportler sportlerin und mannschaft
des jahres die bahnrad
olympiasiegerinnen glänzten genauso wie
ihre olympischen goldmedaillen die
mannschaft des jahres dominierte das
gesamte jahr lieferte mehrere
weltrekorde wurde europameister und
weltmeister nach einem herausragenden
jahr wurde auch alexander zverev zum
ersten mal sportler des jahres er krönte
sich zum ersten deutschen olympiasieger
im einzel und gewann auch die atp-finals
aller guten dinge sind drei mal ag
hamburg ist erneut sportlerin des jahres
sie gewann mit ihrem sieben meter sprung
im letzten versuch des olympischen
finale doch noch gold
schmucke kleidern toller abend was
schlanken das team ja das war schon sehr
fesch allerdings auch die sonne die es
fast überall gearbeitet hat ja ohne
verklärt gleich ob es dann auch so
weiter geht nachher wie gewohnt um 21
uhr 45 das heute journal mit marietta
slomka jetzt erst mal das zdf spezial
zur corona lager in allen noch einen
entspannten abend und gerne bis morgen
um 7
[Musik]
guten abend wenn sie auch in den letzten
tagen die sonne vermisst haben dann
haben sie sich heute bestimmt über das
hoch an ihn gefreut denn nachdem sich
nebel und hochnebel aufgelöst hatten
schien die sonne zum teil strahlend und
nur hier im nordosten waren die wolken
etwas dichter von nordosten kommen jetzt
auch tiefere temperaturen heran die
allerdings bis weihnachten durchhalten
ist unklar denn mit dem tief über dem
atlantik wird es schon gleich wieder von
südwesten milder nicht in dieser nacht
da droht strenger frost über den schnee
flächen am alpenrand mit minus 12 grad
sonst sinken die werte auf 0 bis -7 grad
häufig ist es klar manchmal bildet sich
nebel und hochnebel und nun im nordosten
sind die wolken etwas dichter und dem
erzgebirge kann es auch mal leicht
flocken etwas schneegriesel gibt es dann
morgen auch über tag hier im osten
deutschlands nordöstlich der elbe in
schleswig holstein sind einige
regenschauer zu erwarten sonst aber wird
es nach nebel und hochnebel wieder ein
sehr sonniger tag bei temperaturen um
den gefrierpunkt und allenfalls in
nordfriesland geht's mal bis vier grad
rauf und auch am mittwoch ändert sich an
diesem wetter wenig am donnerstag dann
aber kann es in norddeutschland
gefährlich werden wenn der regen auf den
gefrorenen boden fällt guten abend